quatre chiffres pour mieux partager les
informations les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine ont dorénavant lors si
commun un travail porté pendant dix mois
par les équipes des deux départements
on est plus fort à deux que tout seul et
chacun profite aussi de l'expérience de
l'autre et finalement c'est toujours un
ajustement vers le haut et jamais vers
le bas ce que nous voulons mettre en
oeuvre aussi bien à travers la fusion
qu'à travers les progrès que nous
faisons
administrativement techniquement dans
cette fusion celle inverse
c'est donc que c'est l'administration se
met au service de l'usager au service du
citoyen neuf thématiques 250 dispositif
accessible des parcours type pré définis
au des profils le site s'adresse aux
particuliers comme aux professionnels
c'est l'ensemble des aides et des
dispositifs qui sont présentés sur ce
site qui sont regroupés donc en un seul
site
c'est l'avantagé effectivement de ce
projet là c'est qu'ils ont toute
l'information dont ils souhaitent
bénéficier pour constituer leur dossier
dead en hausse et le bon site sur la
partie route on à la voirie les routes
départementales et donc nos usagers vont
pouvoir se dire tiens est ce qu'il y ait
prévu des travaux sur les routes
départementales
donc ce n'est pas un dispositif en tant
que tel mais c'est une manière de ceux
d'avoir de l'information les démarches
peuvent se faire à tout moment de la
journée le site est accessible 24 heures
sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7